a major former Trump staffer is now
predicting that Donald Trump will
ultimately resign the presidency of the
United States and I'm going to have her
comments for you in a moment but listen
we've talked about this before
III every time I say this I get a few
angry emails I don't think Trump is
going to be removed by impeachment I
just don't think it's going to happen
I don't think Donald Trump is going to
resign but I do believe that if Donald
Trump started to seriously believe that
he was at risk of being removed and
possibly facing criminal prosecution I
think that is the one scenario under
which he might resign the former vice
president of the Trump Organization
Barbara rests is saying exactly this
that Trump is acting just the way he
used to act at the Trump Organization
the paranoia the anger flying off the
handle and that he might resign
specifically to save face she said this
to CNN check it out and when Kelly on
Conway's husband says he's unfit for
office do you agree with that assessment
I do yes but I thought that when he was
running and not not for necessarily the
mental reason said they talked about but
because he didn't have the experience
you know lots of different things so how
do you see this ending now does it end
at the ballot box in a year does he make
it to a second term does he resign as a
result of impeachment what do you think
you know it's funny I people ask me that
and I'm thinking you know it's hard to
say my opinion that she because I could
very well be wrong but let me let me
tell you what I thought I mean I think
that he does a lot of things to save
face and and I could give you examples
we don't have time but I mean there are
some things that you know he can't
control and he's now at the point where
he can't control this he can't do
anything about this it would be very
very very bad thing to be impeached
impeached
I don't know that he'd be found guilty
but I don't think he wants to be
impeached I think yeah I think that's
what this panic is about and my gut
tells me he'll leave office Hillary's on
or make some kind of a deal even
depending on what comes out the deal
thing is a bigger and bigger part of
this
once again I don't believe that this is
heading to an impeachment conviction
some in my audience disagree with me but
as soon as that becomes a reality if it
ever does we immediately start getting
into does Trump pull pens down with him
does Trump set mike pence up to pardon
him if he preemptively resigns does he
pull pens down but make a deal for
Pence's replacement with someone that
will pardon him and then there's also a
completely opposite assessment of all of
this which some people are making which
is even though Trump doesn't like the
idea of articles of impeachment there is
a position to be staked out which i
think is a reasonable one that a failed
impeachment attempt or even an inquiry
that doesn't go well could re-energize
Donald Trump's base it could get some
Republicans who were sort of lukewarm on
Trump to just bite the bullet and vote
for the guy that is not a crazy
prediction about how this could go now
as far as how you know the Barbara res
thing goes of course right away trumpets
are attacking her she's clearly not
clued in to what Trump would do she just
wants to malign Trump she doesn't really
know Trump I even saw some comments
online saying Trump would never sleep
with this woman it is that like even at
issue here I didn't think that that was
on the table anyway this is not a
particularly difficult to believe
assessment I believe that Donald Trump
will do anything he can to not only
avoid impeachment but to avoid
resignation but if it really came down
to it if the rubber really started
meeting the road Trump might resign to
avoid an impeachment conviction Nixon
did it it's not a shocking thing to
think might happen if it went that way
but it's nice to see that the trumpets
immediately identify personal attacks
against a woman as the way to defend
Donald Trump against any critical
statement against their Dear Leader it
completely predictable in every way
Barbara rest let me know what you think
I basically agree with her I think where
I disagree with Barbara rest is I don't
believe this scenario will come to pass
I do agree that to save face a cornered
trump who believes he will be removed by
impeachment would resign
I just don't believe it's going to get
to that point let me know what you think
make sure you are following the show on
twitch at twitch.tv slash david pakman
livestreams will be resuming soon quick
break back after this with much more